bonjour je fais
cette année le thème est
particulièrement facile on a juste à
venir imparfaite comme on est devant
vous c'est pas forcément simple c'est
pas forcément un exercice facile quand
on a essayé de masquer beaucoup ses
imperfections
pourtant on le sait entre vie
personnelle dans notre vie
professionnelle à l'école on sait que
tout n'est pas perfection mais on essaye
quand même moi je fais partie de ceux
qui ont essayé pendant longtemps j'ai
essayé d'avoir des bonnes notes j'ai
essayé d'avoir une bonne filière de
passer un bon back d'avoir une bonne
école pour pouvoir avoir une bonne
carrière un bon salaire une jolie maison
c'est pas forcément simple et c'est pas
forcément facile d'être dans ce tumulte
danse est forcément c'est pas facile je
suis en parfaite du coup je vais me
calmer un peu je vais le faire moins
vite et très rapidement le tumulte
s'installe dans nos vies on est pris
dans cette course effrénée à toujours
plus vite toujours plus haut toujours
plus loin
pourtant le sait on nous l'avait dit et
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez pour
les plus jeunes peut-être que vous vous
en rappelez pas mais un film nous
l'avait dit c'est valentine aller à
sophie marceau qui dans une scène
mémorable nous avez rappelé que tous les
hommes sont menteurs
inconstant faux bavard hypocrite
orgueilleux lâche méprisable et
sensuelle
toutes les femmes sont perfides
artificieuse vaniteuse curieuse et
dépravé tout le monde n'est qu'un égout
sans fond où les phoques les plus sains
forme rampe et se tordent sur des
montagnes de change
mais s'il ya au monde une chose sainte
est sublime c'est l'union de deux êtres
si imparfait et si affreux bon quand
j'étais adolescent que je le connaissais
par coeur on le marquer sur les agendas
de nos copies ne sais pas si vous vous
rappelez mais moi je les fais bref en
tout cas donc on le savait on était un
parfait on le disait mais on
s'appliquait quand même des masques pour
essayer de cacher ses imperfections
je l'ait vraiment fait j'ai eu un bac
avec mention
j'ai passé mon permis j'avais 18 ans et
deux jours bon pour la petite histoire
j'ai grandi dans un département dont la
préfecture et vesoul
ça aide vraiment à passer son permis
rapidement jeu j'ai eu lundi un beau
diplôme américain
parce que bien sûr je voulais parler
anglais sans accent alors je les fais
avec l'accent de chicago je suis rentré
j'ai fait une belle école parisienne
pour pouvoir avoir un beau cv au fur et
à mesure des expériences acquises mon cv
commence à ressembler à quelque chose
sais pas si vous connaissez l'histoire
du pêcheur mexicain bon très bien
visiblement vous connaissez pas alors on
va y aller je vous emmène au mexique
juste pour quelques secondes
un pêcheur mexicain revient après
quelques heures de pêche et sur le
ponton il ya un américain qu'ils à
cliquer là par hasard il est en vacances
et en fait ils voient la pêche super
rebelle de ce pêcheur et lui dit il dit
donc je vais pas vous faire l'accent ni
américain ni mexicain et dis donc elle
est super belle ta pêche t'as mis
longtemps et le mexicain lui répond non
pas trop quelques heures ah bon mais
pourquoi t'as pas pêcher plus longtemps
elles mexicain lui explique que ça sert
à rien en fait il a assez pour subvenir
aux besoins de sa famille et que le
reste du temps en fait il fait la sieste
il joue avec ses enfants
il y passe du temps avec sa femme le
soir il fait à dîner après il va boire
des coups ex époux de faire de la
musique dans le bar du coin et
l'américain lui dit mais attends moi
j'ai un mba de harvard je vais
t'expliquer comment tu vas faire est
vraiment ta vie va être vachement mieux
tu vas déjà restés un petit peu plus
longtemps chaque jour en mer tu va
pêcher plus avec les bénéfices que tu va
dégager
tu vas t'acheter un deuxième bateau puis
un troisième quand tu auras ta flotte de
bateaux tu aura forcément une meilleure
force de négociation avec ton
intermédiaires qui transforme son
poisson et du coup comme ça ça ira mieux
ok le mexicain lui dit ah bon d'accord
mais ça va prendre combien de temps wac
15 ans 20 ans mais après tu pourras t'en
sortir tu pourras déménagé du praj à los
angeles
peut-être même à new york et puis après
là tu pourra introduire tonton group
holding en bourse et là vraiment ça va
être très intéressant et tu tu vas est
riche à millions de mexicains midi mais
d'accord mais après après tu pourras
prendre ta retraite
et puis tu pourras tu installé dans une
petite maison au bord de la plage faire
la sieste te mettre à la retraite
et puis profiter de tes petits enfants
passer du temps avec ta femme puis le
soir tu ira boire des coups avec tes
copains faire de la musique
on voyait venir pardon du coup on a tous
en nous un petit mexicain un petit
américain et on essaye de trouver que
cette balance cet équilibre on est tous
moi j'ai vraiment été conditionné par
tout ça parce un rythme et parfois
certains d'entre nous dans une quête de
sens dans une prise de perspective où l
accident de la vie nous fait prendre un
sens différent nous fait prendre
ça va venir je sais nous nous fait
prendre de la hauteur et nous changer un
peu notre mode de vie
moi c'est un coup c'est un coup de
téléphone qui a changé ma vie un coup de
téléphone de mon médecin gynécologue
tu m'as dit madame ça va être un petit
peu plus compliqué pour vous d'avoir un
enfant je vais vous je vais vous
conseiller un de mes confrères et je
vais vous demander de suivre un parcours
en procréation médicalement assistée
j'étais journaliste dans la santé à
l'époque je savais très bien ce que
c'était la paix m
mais ça me touche et pas forcément
personnellement ni humainement
du coup forcément je suis allé voir sur
google
tous ces parcours tous ces gens toutes
ces tranches de vie
c'est pas simple de se dire que on est
au pied d'une grande montagne et que
peut-être on va y arriver peut-être on
va pas y arriver je dis pas qu'une femme
qui n'est pas mère n'est pas parfaite
cissé choisi si c'est assumer c'est une
perfection moi ma perfection elle était
avec des rires d'enfants
elle était avec des taches de confiture
elle était avec des histoires du soir et
du coup le fait que mon corps soit un
parfait c'était parce que j'étais
c'était parce que je pensais c'était
parce que je faisais était un parfait
donc c'était vraiment moi c'était mon
corps je pouvais rien y faire du coup
les réflexes on ont repris je me suis
conditionné commun comme un sportif de
haut niveau enfin j'imagine j'ai jamais
été sportif de haut niveau mais j'ai
arrêté de fumer
j'ai mangé sainement j'ai fait du sport
j'ai suivi tous les conseils des
médecins j'ai pris toutes les hormones
qu'il fallait prendre si on m'a vite
j'ai fait de la recrue puncture des
séances de reiki si on m'avait dit de
faire du parachute tous les matins je
l'aurais fait du parachute tous les
matins il ya des choses qui coûtent plus
cher que du parachute eux tous les
matins quand on fait de la pma bref
et puis finalement au fil des tentatives
au fil des échecs au fil des mois
et ça c'est sous l'impulsion de mon
amoureux on a décidé de de s'extraire de
ce tumulte de s'extraire de cette vie
dans laquelle on s'était inscrit qu on
avait choisi et j'ai quitté mon travail
on a vendu notre appartement et on a
quitté paris alors quand on est un pma
on entend toujours trois milliards
d'histoire et là vous in truc qui est
tombée enceinte alors qu'elle tout ce
qui à la cousine machin qui est tombée
enceinte alors qu'elle venait d'adopter
on se raccroche des fois ces histoires
des fois nous agace en tout cas nous on
a choisi de nous écouter de s'écouter
nous mêmes on a choisi de de ne plus
aller au repas de famille si on n'avait
pas envie d'y aller de ne pas affronter
certain regard de ne pas affronter
certaines questions quand on en n'avait
pas envie quand on en avait envie on y
allait
on le devait j'ai choisi d'écouter aussi
ma colère quand je voyais des femmes
enceintes
des fois je les supportaient pas des
fois je les supporter et pourtant je
sais très bien que c'est injuste que ll
n'y pouvait rien et c'était juste j'ai
accepté la colère j'ai accepté de
l'assumer je vous sens un peu fébrile
sur le déroulement là et ben n'empêche
que ça a marché
je suis tombée enceinte et j'ai donné
naissance à un merveilleux petit garçon
et du coup quelques mois après on s'est
vraiment dit que on voulait pas retomber
dans ce rythme effréné
on voulait pas repartir dans cette quête
et on a eu la chance et l'opportunité de
pouvoir s'installer à la réunion
alors bien sûr il faut travailler ici
aussi il y à il ya des choses mais vous
admettrez quand même qu'on est vachement
mieux à la réunion que enfermé dans un
périphérique parisien où il fait gris
plus souvent qu ici et du coup on a
vraiment eu une belle chance pour saint
stade de s'installer ici
magie de la nature récompense de je sais
pas quoi notre petite fille est arrivée
juste après notre arrivée et ça c'était
un vrai moment de bonheur aussi bien sûr
fut pas une mère parfaite
bien au contraire je crois que quelqu'un
nous dira qu on est tous imparfaits dans
la parentalité un peu plus tard j'ai
souvent une tâche sur mes vêtements puis
souvent fatigué j'arrive en retard
souvent je perds mon calme parfois je
dois faire face comme tout le monde au
stress du quotidien aux injonctions de
la société il faut perdre ses kilos
avant l'été
bon bah quand on vit à la réunion vous
allez perdre tout le temps alors tant
pis tant pis je vais continuer à assumer
les questions de mes enfants qui me
demande régulièrement si j'ai encore un
bébé dans le ventre parce que je
n'arrive pas à les perdre
il faut arriver au travail fraîches même
quand on a changé deux fois les draps
dans la nuit il faut essayer de
d'être des parents correct essayer de
trouver un bon équilibre entre vie
familiale vie professionnelle
on fait régulièrement
face à cette pression bien entendu je
vais pas parler de la charge mentale ça
serait pas très équitable je connais pas
un couple qui s'est pas engueulé sur la
charge mentale mais du coup comme là je
suis dans un exercice de monologues je
vais je vais vous passer cet
ce sujet et puis mais finalement je m'en
sors pas si mal il s'occupe souvent du
dîner et plein de choses encore je dis
pas seulement ça parce qu'il est là bien
sûr on fait tous comme on peut avec ce
qu'on a
maintenant tout ce parcours mort a
montré comme en fait il ya bien une
chose qui est importante c'est le moment
présent c'est le moment qu'on vit là
tous les quatre à la réunion avec nos
deux petits bouts souvent la maison des
parents j'ai souvent les repas sont pas
équilibrés souvent on va fermer la porte
sur le bazar pour vite courir et ne pas
louper le coucher de soleil pour savoir
lequel de nos 4 va voir le soleil vert
tant pis pour le rangement tant pis pour
les vêtements sales tant pis pour la
machine qui n'est pas étendu parce que
s'il ya bien quelque chose qui est le
plus important c'est de profiter avec
eux de ce moment là c'est bien pour ça
qu on avait tellement envie d'être
parents est souvent grâce à ceux qui ont
eu des enfants avant nous et que je vois
obligé de payer des billets d'avion pour
pouvoir passer noël tous ensemble ou
quand je vois que avec mes frères et
soeurs ça fait des années qu'on n'a pas
été à table tous ensemble avec nos
parents quand je me rends compte que un
jour il faudra que je fasse un doodle
pour les avoir a dîné tous en même temps
quand il faudrait que les supplie pour
qu'ils viennent passer un week end avec
leurs vieux parents je les vois se
chamailler devant moi je les vois se
disputer un grain de riz ou un jouet ou
je sais pas quoi et je profite
pleinement de ce moment là parce que je
sais qu'à un moment donné
peut-être dans dix ans peut-être dans 15
ans je le regretterai ces moments là
donc voilà je voulais juste partager
avec vous ce petit cette petite
expérience et si vous voulez qu'on en
parle après je serai là aussi merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]